تسعه طويله هي عصابات في السودان سببت
حاله من الترويع والتوجس هي عصابات متخصصه
بالنهب والسرقه بالاكراه يظهرون على
الدراجات الناريه ولديهم طريقه معينه
بالنهب والهروب بسرعه البرق وحالات السرقه
بواسطه العصابه المذكوره وحراميه اخرين
تشهد ارتفاعا في مدن السودان المختلفه
مؤخرا شرطه ولايه الجزيره في محاوله
للتعامل مع الظاهره والحد من حالات السرقه
قررت اتباع اسلوب جديد واعلنت عنه في
منشور على حسابها على فيسبوك وفي المنشور
كما ترون اعلنت الشرطه ان هذه رساله لكل
من تسول نفسه العبث بممتلكات المواطنين
وانها ستقبض على هؤلاء وتصورهم لايف
ليراهم العالم ويتعرفون عليهم الشرطه يبدو
انها استبقت وتوقعت معارضه البعض للقرار
تبررت وقالت ردا على كل من يعتبر هذا
تشييرا وانتهاكا لح قوق الشخصيه ان السرقه
وترويع المواطنين اكبر مهدد وفيه انتهاك
لحقوق ايضا وبالفعل بدات فورا بعضها
بتطبيق القرار ونشرت فيديو اعترافات مع
شخص اسمته اخطر معتدي سرقات النشر
شغال شغال
مئات السودانيين دخلوا فورا على منشور
الشرطه على فيسبوك وعلق ومرحبين ومؤيدين
للقرار الذي راوه رادعا لللصوص وعصابات
تسعه طويله وحتى البعض تمنى لو قرارا كهذا
اتخذ من زمن بعيد
كما شاهدتم الغالبيه العظمى من المعلق
المؤيدين للقرار ومرحبين به وطمحي لان
يكون رادعا للصوص والنشالين لكن ايضا على
اصوات المعارضه للقرار وترفيه تشهيدا وانه
قد يفاقم الازمه ولا يحلها والبعض تساءلوا
ان كان الامر قانونيا اصلا
وللحديث اكثر عن الموضوع معنا من الخرطوم
المحامي اياد قاسم خالد اهلا بك استاذ
اياد انت محامي ومدافع عن حقوق الانسان شو
رايك بهذا القرار للشرطه
اهلا بك مساء الخير واهلا بضيوفك الكرام
وجميع المشاهدين
ابتداء لايصال المعلومه كامله في ظل
القانون السوداني او قانون الاجراءات
الجنائيه السوداني لسنه 1991 وهو القانون
المختص بالاجراءات التي تتخذها النيابه
عبر الادوات التنفيذيه وهي الشرطه
للبحث واستقصاء البينات والتحريات
تمر الدعوه الجنائيه في القانون السوداني
بمرحلتين مرحله التحقيقات ومرحله المحاكمه
نتحدث الان عن مرحله التحقيقات او مرحله
البريترايل
والتي يكون فيها للنيابه سلطات واسعه حول
الضبط والتفتيش والقط
لكن بالحديث عن هذه المرحله انا ارى ان
هذا
الحدث او حتى هذه الظاهره ظاهره التسعه
طويله مع كامل التضامن مع كل ضحاياها وكل
من وقع ضحيه لهذه الجريمه الا انه لا يمكن
ان نصل بالاجراء
متطرفين الى حد تصوير المتهمين وعرضهم
امام الاعلام وامام المجتمع ونحن في هذه
المرحله من التحريات حيث ان داخل القانون
الاجرائي السوداني في الماده الرابعه منه
في الفقره الجيم تنص على مبدا اصيل وهو
براءه المتهم حتى تثبت ادانته والحق في
المحاكمه العادله والناجزه يتفق هذا
المبدا مع الاتفاقيه الدوليه للحقوق
المدنيه والسياسيه لسنه 1996 والتي نصت
على ذات الله المبدا الاصيل في براءه
المتهم ومن هذا نجد ان هذا الفعل قد يشكل
ايدان اجتماعيه وادانه اعلاميه في مرحله
ما قبل المحاكمه وما قبل اكتمال البينات
التي ترتقي الى توجيه التهمه واحاله
البلاغ الى المحكمه وهي المختصه تحت مبدعه
علنيه الجلسات بالسماح بالتصوير اثناء
المحاكمه وخلافه
الاخر يقول ان تصويرهم ليس مخالفا للقانون
انه يدعم تحقيق العداله حتى ان بعض
القانونيين اتفقوا على هذا الراي ما رايت
انا ارى ان تصويرهم في هذه المرحله من
التحريات ومرحله ما قبل المحاكمه هو اجراء
متاسف ومتطرف تجاه متهم او مشتبه به لم
تكتمل البيانات في مواجهته ولم يحصل على
ادانه امام قاضي طبيعي امام محكمه طبيعيه
بحسب سير الله الامور وبحسب الحق في
المحاكمه العادله حيث انه قد يتم اطلاق
سراحه لعدم اكتمال البيانات او قد يتم
احالته الى المحكمه وتبرئته عبر المحكمه
بينما نكون قد سبق السيف العزم وتم ادانته
عبر الاعلام وعبر المجتمع بعد كل ان هذا
ارجاء قد يخفف من حالات النشر
والاعتداءات التي تحصل في السودان كيف
تفسر هذا الاجماع شبه الاجماع على ضروره
يعني كشف هؤلاء اللصوص امام العامه
انا ايضا اسكن السودان واعيش في الخرطوم
واجهت مثل هذه الحوادث واتفهم السخط
الاجتماعي وحاله الغضب تجاه تمدد هذه
الظاهره الا ان المعالجه لهذه الظاهره لا
يمكن ان تكون بالتسف والتطرف في استخدام
القانون وقد يرقى الى مخالفته حيث ان
الماده 43 من ذات قانون الاجراءات
الجنائيه ينص على حظر التاثير على التحريم
واي من اطراف التحرير التي يكون بالتاكيد
طرفا منها هو المتهم وهذا التاثير قد يكون
بالاغراء او بالاكراه
حيث ان هذا المتهم قد يقر بالله بالتهمه
فقط
مكرها حتى لا يتم تصويره او نشره على
الملا
كيف يمكن حل هذه الظاهره التي
الصيدلينيين بشكل عام
انا في كامل الثقه ان مؤسسه الشرطه
السودانيه هي اكثر من قادره او مختلف في
ادارات المباحث وادارات التحقيقات
الجنائيه للوصول للمعلومات التي قد تمكن
من كسر هذه الشبكات الاجراميه ايضا اثق في
القضاء السوداني الذي سياخذ هذه الظاهره
على محمل الجد وعلى خطرها على المجتمع وقد
يصل فيها الى احكام
ممكن فلنقل العقوبه القصوى من اجل الردع
وهي العقوبه العقوبه في القانون السوداني
فلسفه وقانونا هي من اجل الردع وليست من
اجل التشفي او الانتقام من المتهم او
المدان حتى
بمعنى المحامي اياد قاسم خالد شكرا جزيلا
لك
[موسيقى]